lleva el círculo unitario a cada círculo
usando traslaciones y potencias y bueno
este es el círculo unitario justo este
de aquí el cual está centrado en el 0 0
en el origen y tiene un radio de 1 es
por esto que lo llamamos círculo
unitario y cuando dice lleva el círculo
unitario a cada círculo usando
traslación es bueno traslación es
significa mover al círculo así que esto
de aquí sería una traslación o motes
jazz o potencia significa a hacer el
círculo más grande o más pequeño
entonces vamos a usar traslación es
potencias para llevar el círculo
unitario y qué te parece si empezamos
con el círculo magenta así que por
ejemplo puedo trasladar el centro de
nuestro círculo unitario al centro del
círculo magenta y después puedo hacer la
potencia es decir voy a hacer crecer el
ciclo unitario hasta llegar al círculo
magenta esto es mapear el círculo
unitario al círculo magenta y puedo
hacer unos más vamos a hacerlo
no voy a hacer todos pero lo que sí
quiero es que ustedes una de lo que
estoy hablando ahora voy a trasladar el
centro de mi círculo unitario alargado y
lo voy a mover al centro del círculo
morado y después voy a hacerlo motes ya
hasta tener el mismo radio
y observa que pueda mapear lo si puedes
mapear una figura a otra solamente con
traslación es potencias entonces por
definición esas figuras serán semejantes
ahora bien otra forma de pensar este
ejercicio es ver que todos los círculos
son semejantes si tú tomas cualquier
círculo y lleva a su centro al centro de
otro círculo y después lo escalas ya sea
más grande o más pequeño entonces más
veas tu círculo original al otro círculo
así que aquí lo tienes espero que esto
te dé la idea de que todos los círculos
son semejantes